c'est vrai, Chris Columbus est à peu près le
meilleur être humain que j'ai jamais rencontré,
génial, c'est le cinéaste de notre consulat, vous
pouvez dire qu'il était juste dans ces poèmes, il
est responsable de bon nombre de mes
films préférés ayant écrit Goonies
et Gremlins ou réalisé le premier à
Harry Potter est seul à la maison et Mme.
Doubtfire Adam Sandler m'a dit que j'avais
ce super script, c'est comme si je l'avais lu et je me suis
rendu compte que tout était si original, si
unique - ça a changé la donne, j'ai dû le faire,
c'est tellement dans le domaine de ce que Chris
fait si brillamment, ils doivent obtenir la
ceinture.  et me concentrer sur la conduite en
même temps, ce qui donne
vie à ces mondes merveilleusement fantastiques
avec ces personnages incroyablement riches et décalés. Les
pixels me permettent de pousser la
comédie aussi loin que possible
mais aussi de créer ce
film d'action-aventure très intense et très nerveux après avoir fait
effets visuels dans le passé, mais nous
visions ici, c'est quelque chose que vous n'avez jamais
vu auparavant, quelque chose de si
complètement original et unique que le
public aurait le souffle coupé quand il
le verrait pour la première fois, si vous ne pouvez pas le voir, il le
fait toujours.  sait exactement ce qui va se passer
dans ces productions
et il pourrait simplement vous guider, il
sort de l'ombre, c'est devenu fait, donc
c'était l'occasion de créer
quelque chose de vraiment nouveau en utilisant les outils que j'avais
rassemblés au fil des années.